bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne les travaux de la mission
commune d'information du sénat sur
l'organisation territoriale du système
scolaire
il y a quinze jours la mission présenté
un premier bilan d'étape de ces travaux
vous aviez d'ailleurs pu suivre en
direct une table ronde sur notre antenne
à ce sujet ce matin c'est la deuxième
table ronde que je vous propose de
suivre
elle porte sur le fonctionnement du
service public de l'éducation
très bonne matinée à tous alors cette
deuxième table ronde est consacrée à la
question nous avons gelé dit beaucoup
effleuré évoqué de manière indirecte
dans la première table ronde à savoir de
celle de la place des partenaires de
l'éducation qui sont les collectivités
et le lieu dans lequel nous sommes tout
à fait approprié pour poser cette
question là bien évidemment et c'est
aussi vous l'avez
vous l'avez vu le thème de la de la
mission alors fonctionnement du service
public de l'éducation du cloisonnement
au partenariat pour fixer le cadre de
serre de cette un tas de cette table
ronde
je vous rappellerai quand même deux
éléments importants dans l'actualité
récente la rfa a tout à fait récemment
réclamé la compétence région vous
connaissez l'historique
de ce transfert puisque on a pendant
l'acte 2 de la décentralisation hésité
sur le transfert de cette compétence
pour finalement revenir en arrière
donc la question semble se reposer ces
temps ci le terme d' acte iii de la
décentralisation se pose assez
régulièrement
on l'entend dans la bouche de certains
syndicats en entendant la bouche
d'acteurs de l'éducation et enfin le
terme de contractualisation tripartite
qui est un mot barbare pour dire qu'il
faut plus faire travailler ensemble
l'état les collectivités et
et
j'en oublie le troisième et le monde
socio-économique en tout cas
concrètement pour la question dino zoo
qui nous occupe ça serait rectorat
collectivités et ministère donc est ce
que cette contractualisation tripartite
est possible c'est la question qu'on va
qu'on va aborder alors il ya de nombreux
intervenants qui sont prévus pour cette
table ronde qui va être structurée de la
manière suivante pour qu'on puisse être
le plus efficace possible
nous aurons d'abord de retour
d'expérience une sur une
collectivités une mairie avec monsieur
daniel dubois qui est président de la
communauté de la communauté de communes
pardon d'aï le haut clocher dans la
somme et qui est également membre de la
mission commune d'information
et puis ensuite nous passerons la parole
à
deux représentants des ministères des
pays-bas du ministère de l'éducation
nationale des pays bas alors je ne
traiterai pas en semi d'albarn service
mais vous allez nous expliquer qu'ils
vous représentez un tandem qui nous a
fait le plaisir d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui et qui nous montrera comment
fonctionne le système hollandais et
ensuite nous aurons différents acteurs
observateurs qui interviendront autour
de ces deux expériences
donc je demanderai à chacun d'être bref
qu'on puisse là encore avoir le temps de
débattre avec la salle je laisse tout de
suite la parole avec cette
recommandation à daniel dubois
donc je les dis vous allez nous
présenter l'expérience que vous avez
menées dans votre commune mais où merci
bonjour à tous à tout je suis
effectivement que président de la
communauté de communes du haut clocher
qui est une communauté de communes
rurales de 20 communes 8000 habitants en
proximité de la baie de somme g salue
d'ailleurs les maires des trois communes
qui accueillent la rpc qui sont ici
présents et donc est ce que finalement
notre communauté de communes a innové
expérimenté point d'interrogation en
tous les cas la restructurer elle a
volontairement restructurait sa veut
dire qu'il y a eu une démarche politique
majeur sur ce territoire
est-ce que nous étions finalement dans
la tente de voir nos écoles se fermer
les unes derrière les autres et
puisqu'on est composé de petites
communes rurales
est-ce que nous étions dans la tente de
voir ray la pédagogie numérique
s'installer en ville
évitez notre territoire rural
est-ce que nous étions dans la tente de
voir finalement les enseignants défilent
et ray dans les petites écoles parce que
la rotation est importante ou au
contraire ou décidions de nous engager
volontairement dans cette
restructuration de l'école en milieu
rural j'ai entendu parler de tout à
l'heure de transfert de financement de
l'état vers les collectivités
moi je voudrais vous dire ici que la
collectivité quasiment unanimement a
pris la décision de dire nous allons
dépenser
plus pour les cols mais nous allons le
faire ensemble et nous allons donner les
moyens aux enfants de notre territoire
d'avoir les mêmes chances que ceux de la
ville et que sur le territoire quel que
soit l'endroit les équipements et les
les équipements et les écoles soit au
même niveau pour que le service soit le
même pour tous les enfants je donne un
seul exemple nous avions fait évaluer
l'engagement des collectivités dans
leurs écoles y en avait 13
ça allait de 6 euros par habitant dans
certaines écoles à 86 euros par habitant
dans d'autres il y avait donc un tel
écart qu'il nous paraissait nécessaire
serait de remettre alors est ce là sur
la table et donc de réfléchir ensemble
je vais essayer des filets si c'est
possible ça va pas très vite
alors les objectifs de ce travail
communautaire
donc je viens de vous dire assurer une
égalité des chances pour les élèves
garantir une équité apporter de
meilleures conditions matérielles
c'est très lent et que six minutes voilà
travail en équipe dans l'école lien
écoles collèges meilleure stabilité de
l'équipe enseignante mise en place d'un
projet éducatif évidemment espace dédié
voilà alors ceci étant dit je voudrais
préciser une chose
cela a pris 7 en ces temps de débat
s'étend de dialogue ça a commencé en
2003 les choses sérieuses devraient se
sont engagés en 2005 et la communauté de
communes a pris la compétence en 2007 et
ensuite on a eu 1 les bains débat
extrêmement complexe pour savoir combien
d'écoles moderne du 21e siècle nous
allions construire pour remplacer ses
traits écoles il y a il y avait sept
cent cinquante élèves scolarisés à
l'époque sur le territoire et donc nous
avons fait le choix de construire trois
écoles les écoles sont ouverts donc
depuis cette année donc compétence
scolaire communautaire décision de
construire trois écoles à la place de 13
et ensuite naturellement sectorisation
dans l'école
alors ces écoles vous l'imaginez bien
sont des écoles une ré en haute qualité
environnementale il n'y a pas de fioul
ni de gaz est vrai dans les écoles ce
sont trois écoles numériques avec un
point essentiel il ya le très haut débit
dans les trois écoles parce que c'est
très bien de mettre de tvi dans les
écoles rurales
mais si vous avez l'adsl à moins de 5
181,9 kilo bits
ça veut dire que vous avez un tvi qui
fonctionne ou deux éventuellement mais
si vous en mettez un troisième et qui
est un ordinateur qui fonctionne en fond
de classe il y en a un qui est en rade
c'est donc dire qu'à un moment donné
ouais il y a une vraie problématique
majeure poser en termes d'équité sur les
territoires ruraux
j'insiste donc nos écoles sont fibre
optique tableaux blancs interactifs dans
toutes les classes écoles mobiles de 30
ordinateurs et spa
numérique de travail donc qui crée
l'interaction entre l'enfant
l'enseignant et les parents et surtout
assez bien cybercentre médiathèque dans
chacune de ces écoles ouverts aux
parents ce qui fait que on a créé là
aussi je veux dire un certain
décloisonnement avec les parents puisque
l'école leur est ouverte reste dans
certaines plages avec un fonctionnement
n'ont rien proposé aux parents alors je
ne parle pas du périscolaire qui
naturellement est aux normes avec les
cantines il y aurait des haltes
garderies qui sont mises en oeuvre et et
notre réflexion avait porté sur notre
territoire
cette réflexion gérer de la réussite
scolaire elle prenait bien en compte ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure par
plusieurs intervenants la parentalité
est engagée évidemment le politique est
un partenaire et il doit être n'aurait
pris en compte comme un partenaire par
l'éducation nationale
ça nous paraît être une évidence alors
maintenant ces écoles sont ouvertes
elles sont en train de fonctionner
naturellement il ya eu une gouvernance
qui a été mis en place pour que ces
écoles sorte les voilà à 1 construite
voyez ces trois écoles je vais défiler
assez vite donc dans cette école il ya
300 élèves
elle est située juste à côté du collège
il ya deux salles de sport à côté une
salle culturelle et tout est en fibre
optique sur ce territoire
la deuxième école étape on ré mi c'est
une école qui a été restructurée la
commune a engagé
j'en profite pour le dire sur ces fonds
la construction d'un petit gymnase juste
à côté de l'école
donc il va ouvrir prochainement et l
école de saint riquier au pied de
l'abbatiale de saint riquier
donc où l'histoire nous dit que
charlemagne est passé puisqu'elle était
à l'origine carolingienne donc cette
école gré et sous le regard de
charlemagne et là nous avons donc dit
classe donc douze classes saïdi classe à
saré pied et huit classes apport et me
voilà les tableaux blancs interactifs
qui fonctionnent les médiathèques
ouverte aux parents les restaurants
scolaires les coûts 10 millions d'euros
notre collectivité qui a 8000 habitants
a engagé dix mille euros pour les écoles
iii sur ses fonds enfin un million et
demi sur ses fonds propres
un million et demi d'emprunt et
naturellement nous avons eu des
partenaires
puisqu'on parle des partenariats
effectivement les partenariats étaient
nécessaires pour financer un tel projet
est donc le conseil général s'est engagé
la région s'est engagée à nos côtés
l'état s'est engagé s'est engagé à nos
côtés
l'europe s'est engagée à nos côtés pour
ans pour mettre ce projet mais notre
communauté de communes petites
communautés de communes rurales a engagé
3 millions d'euros pour faire en sorte
qu effectivement les gamins de ce
territoire et les mêmes changerait que
les autres ceci étant dit nous
considérons que ce n'est pas suffisant
alors là j'ai un petit dysfonctionnement
c'est pas comment ça se fait alors je
vais terminer ces derniers le dernier ce
live nous considérons que effectivement
le décloisonnement n'est pas suffisant
nous nous sommes engagés nous avons
décloisonner au niveau des territoires
des politiques
nous avons travaillé en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale à travers un
comité de pilotage
on a d'ailleurs eu trois inspecteurs
d'académie différents auraient pendant
les politiques qui ont été menées pour
réaliser ce projet les élus se sont
énormément engagée il ya plus de 300
réunions sur le territoire pour réussir
cela
aujourd'hui nous nous engageons dans une
convention culturelle avec le conseil
général et le pays pour qu'ils y aient
3.33 actions culturelles qu'ils soient
menées dans c dans ces écoles
nous nous engageons avec le conseil
général puisqu'il lance une
expérimentation sur éducation et
territoires et nous souhaitons et nous
souhaitons et genre et j'en viens au
débat qui a été engagé tout à l'heure
nous souhaitons une évaluation nous
souhaitons qu effectivement avec
l'éducation nationale nous ayons un réel
partenariat pour poursuivre la démarche
qui a été engagée aujourd'hui moi j'ai
la chance d'avoir des enseignants qui
travaillent en relation directe avec des
écoles jumelée avec l'allemagne avec
l'angleterre est parce que ils ont les
moyens spécifiques de le faire mais on
aimerait que l'éducation nationale soit
encore plus présente à nos côtés évalue
évalue est-ce que ça s'améliore est-ce
que les équipements sont adaptés ou
faut-il aller vers autre chose et
construire localement un conseil de
l'éducation
pour que j'aurais nous ayons en
partenariat avec tous les acteurs que ce
soit les parents les représentants de
parents le conseil général avec ses
services sociaux bien sûr l'éducation
nationale les élus la caisse
d'allocations familiales
un regard croisé qui s'installe sur le
territoire et qui permet aux raids des
valuées correctement ce que nous avons
mis en
merci beaucoup pour cette courte
présentation je laisse la parole à
madame carla phone koppenberg je sais
pas si je prononce bien on me reprendrai
certainement qui est inspectrice seniors
de l'éducation aux pays bas est-ce son
intervention sera suivie de celle de
monsieur eugène bernard président du
conseil d'administration d'un réseau
d'établissements aux pays bas qui porte
le nom de hans michelbach under vie je
vous laisse la parole d'abord bonjour à
tout le monde
merci de deux invitations ça marche il
faut que je suis plus près du micro
merci de l'invitation de vous parler
permettez moi de
vous remercier et de dire que mon
collègue de pays bas et moi même sont
l'exemple vivant de la coopération
nationale parce que de nous deux ils
sont un exemple vivant que la
coopération marche aux pays-bas entre le
service
du service public et du monde de
l'éducation et le monde scolaire
monsieur bernard vous en parlera plus
tard avant que j'ai commencé j'aimerais
vous décrire quelques points
caractéristiques du système il que tu
fais des pays-bas pour entrer au détail
sur l'ensemble des responsabilités
partagées et moi je m'occuperai du
niveau national notre pays connaît une
longue tradition de libre choix
concernant l'éducation s'est même
introduit dans notre constitution ça
veut dire que les parents choisissent
leur école ils ont le droit de fonder
une icône et ça veut dire que nous
n'avons pas de calculs nationale
prescrit par conséquence les conseils
d'administration des établissements
scolaires sont relativement autonome se
doit ce contexte de libre choix implique
que le système d'enseignement est
fortement décentralisé
c'est à dire que les écoles choisissent
leur statut soit public soit privé et
établissent leurs programmes
d'enseignement le financement est
publique
par contre nous avons des examens
centralisée en fin d'études secondaires
baccalauréat et autres tous les élèves
passent les mêmes examens aux mêmes
jours et ensuite
pour vous montrer que ne sais tu ce
n'est pas toujours libre on peut dire
que nous avons afin d'établir plus de
transparence dans la qualité attendue de
l'éducation nous avons défini au niveau
national des niveaux de base qui servent
de cadre de référence national des
performances attendues des jeunes dont
les matières considérer indispensable de
cette dire arrête nick arithmétique
mathématiques et langue maternelle dans
les années 90 du siècle dernier dans
notre système éducatif
pas mal de réformes ont été introduites
quand vous vous payez vous pouvez vous
imaginer pas toutes les innovations ont
été un grand succès ou une réussite
partout raison pour laquelle une
émulation des réussites et des échecs a
été faite il ya quatre ans
concernant les innovations du système
éducatif et elle était organisée par le
biais d'une enquête parlementaire
la conclusion principale a été que il
faut bien une répartition claire des
rôles et responsabilités
elle est indispensable est importante
entre l'état et les établissements
scolaires à ce niveau c'est à dire les
déterminent ce que chaque élève doit
avoir appris à la fin d'un cycle
nous appelons cela le quoi tandis que
les applis établissements scolaires
détermine comment elles vont atteindre
les résultats attendus
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de quoi par
exemple vous pouvez penser à des
objectifs ciblés par secteur
un temps comme un des programmes
d'examen une base de connaissances des
niveaux de référence en en maternelle et
en arrêt technique et des compétences
professionnelles bien sûr aussi
comparable dans le cadre de youpine
qualification frimeur
comment le ministre jeetah question son
temps avec la province pédagogique on se
met d'accord sur des accords de
réalisation est un ange en orient d'art
de qualité
par secteurs conformes les accords entre
les ministres et les incitations aux
flyers du secteur ou bien dit des
organisations de bronze
ce que je voulais pour conclure vous
décrire c'est que comment au niveau
national on l'appelle le niveau macro
les interdépendances et les
responsabilités sont partagées au niveau
macro dont le système éducatif
d'irlandais chaque année au parlement
l'inspecteur général et c'est une fois
un inspecteur donc le contexte français
mais c'est le directeur de l'inspection
nationale est elle présente deux
rapports nationale concernant la
situation qualitative du système sa
soeur qui a été présentée le 20 avril
dans chaque secteur et par secteur je
veux dire pour l'enseignement primaire
pour danser mon secondaire le ministre
présente son agenda stratégique qu
adrian concernant l'amélioration de la
qualité suivant les critères de
performance qui ont été convenues avec
les associations employeurs et c'est ça
se fait par secteur est-ce que qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour
les établissements scolaires monsieur
bernard vous on parlera plus en détail
un peu plus tard il ya une
responsabilisation et des comptes rendus
ça veut dire d'abord organisation
verticale
le conseil d'accusation établi son
rapport annuel concernant les résultats
obtenus moyenne un protocole de contrôle
fournis par le ministère
puis le conseil d'ordre corps de ce
rapport annuel dont le quitus ne sais
pas si un terme qui est utilisé beaucoup
en français le rapport annuel est
présenté au ministère le rapport annuel
est un des trois supports utilisés par
l'inspection pour déterminer le niveau
de contrôle qualité annuel et là on
distingue trois niveaux
la plupart des établissements après une
analyse de risques aura un contrôle de
dison la base de qualité est
suffisamment bon ordre et où il ya des
possibilités on aura un feu orange ou
même des fûts rouge le niveau de
contrôle annuel est la traduction
opérationnelle du niveau de confiance
que l'état et les citoyens peuvent avoir
dont la qualité des prestations
éducatives fournit le deuxième support
utilisé par l'inspection concerne les
résultats obtenus des élèves et ça se
passe par section le troisième support
est constitué de l'ensemble de signaux
émanant de l'activité éducative reçu est
captée par l'inspection de l'année et
comment tout cela est organisé
du point de vue du conseil
d'administration monsieur bernard vous
on va expliquer par la suite pour un
grand d'organes est un organisme qui
s'appelle on se met pas au nord-est et
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup aux malades
vous pouvez peut-être nous expliquer ce
que ce qui est en semi d'alba commencer
si j'ai bien compris c'est un réseau
d'établissements
oui tout à fait dans mon nom est eugène
verdun
montano et dalaba si vous décerner un
accès en français c'est normal je suis
français d'origine
mais parlons maintenant depuis 20 ans ou
bien anglais ou bien leur hollandais des
fois juste doit chercher mes mots en
français donc si des fois j'accroche
quelque part vous saurez pourquoi c'est
un réseau effectivement donc
contrairement à l'introduction je ne
suis pas du ministère je ne suis même
pas fonctionnaire mais quand même
responsable d'un groupe d'écoles où nous
employons donc nous sommes l'employeur
attention de 6000 employés et nous
essayons de donner un bon enseignement à
peu près 60 mille élèves
je vous dis ça comme ça pour vous donner
une petite idée de de quel type
d'organisation il s'agit d'autres
budgets annuels on est à peu près 1 1 2
milliard par an à peu près donc soixante
mille élèves un demi milliard six mille
ans prier madame fomc à aubert fait
partie de l'inspection et nous
travaillons ensemble donc l'inspection
c'est eux qui ne contrôle qui donc qui
vont qui viennent voir une fois par an
ou bien une fois en trois ans si nous
travaillons bien mais sans quoi nous
savons nous trouver chaque fois que nous
avons besoin de l'un de l'autre ce que
je vais vous montrer maintenant c'est
comment ça marche une école ce que vous
voyez donc ici c'est les élèves parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on commence ça a
été dit d'abord dans le premier table
ronde tout le travail que nous faisons
c'est pour les arabes
6-6 a aucune relation avec les élèves on
ne fait pas c'est aussi simple que ça
nous avons un proviseur par école c'est
aussi simple que ça aussi bien conseil
de participation qui est composé de
d'employés de parents et d'élèves et
pour certains ou certaines décisions ce
conseil de participation un droit de
veto d'accord donc c'est
d'ailleurs c'est ses membres la sont
choisis sont choisis sont élus pardon à
côté donc il ya un conseil
d'administration en l'occurrence et bach
ensuite président et donc nous avons un
groupe d'écoles en l'occurrence il
s'agit à peu près d'une centaine
d'écoles et nous avons un conseil
d'ordre qui nous contrôlent aussi
lorsque vous pouvez voir avec toutes les
lignes qui a c'est qu'il ya aucun membre
aucun j'allais dire aucun élément du
système qui peut on peut opérer de façon
complètement autonome
donc chaque élément du système a besoin
de l'autre c'est ce qu'on appelle en
sciences naturelles pour ceux qui aiment
bien c'est en anglais je suis désolé je
ne sais pas en français même pas où elle
incarne paroisse comme vous faites ça
vous avez de l' équilibre
c'est aussi simple que ça donc c'est ce
que disait madame banca aubert a aussi
c'est donc c'est nous qui détermineront
le comment donc nous l'état nous a dit
ce que ce que nous devons faire mais
c'est à nous de décider de faire le
comment donc c'est pour ça que j'ai été
un peu surpris d'avoir le voir le débat
du premier rang de la première table
ronde ici puisque aux pays-bas des
expérimentations mère mon décret puis
voilà d'uptoo pendant qu on n ose
résultat ça un sujet là il ya vraiment
pas de cadeau s'il n'y a pas de
résultats il n'y a pas d'argent on ferme
c'est aussi simple que ça c'est très
sain pour faire une loi comme ça n'est
ce pas messieurs les ré mesdames les
sénateurs c'est que c'est très très très
très simple je me disais bien aussi que
ça ça vous devrait vous plaire
pendant le premier d'ailleurs le premier
truc de la première discussion qui a eu
aussi on parlait souvent du partenariat
au pardon il s'agirait venir tout de
suite le croit donc c'est décidé sa part
le ministère de l'éducation nationale je
veux dire par là par les politiciens etc
qui me contrôler directement donc encore
une fois où vous voyez deux éléments
d'un système qui dépendent l'un de
l'autre
et ensuite ce que vous voyez aussi
sequeira inspection ses marques à aubers
don qui vous apparaît tout de suite
ce qui est important aussi c'est savoir
que la municipalité est un partenaire
aussi et surtout en ce qui concerne
l'immobilier
donc les bâtiments et je vous le disais
tout de suite ça nous sommes notre
propre l'employeur donc monsieur ko
quand il était en visite au pays balle
m'a demandé qu'est ce qui est marqué sur
la fiche de paye des enseignants baisse
est marquée on se met le ballon devant
donc notre organisation à nous d'accord
et nous sommes tous les employeurs sont
associés dans une association
d'employeurs et bien sûr nous avons à
faire avec des indiquent les syndicats
d'employés puisque je vais y revenir
tout de suite aussi pour ce qui concerne
les conditions de travail dont de tout
de suite vous parliez de partenariat
surtout alors que nous nous préférons
parler de copropriété ce qui est
complètement différent et que siki
copropriétaires en autres dents dans
maman demande organisation à moi c'est
les parents et les entreprises disent
audi qui sont donc copropriétaires de
tout ce que je vous disais tout de suite
en fait ce qui a presque comment ça
marche je vais aller très très vite
parce qu'il ya madame mary qui commence
à me regarder un petit peu de chine la
dotation des moyens c'est également très
très très simple les locales je vais y
revenir tout de suite ce que nous
faisons donc un employeur c'est que tous
les ans ou une fois tous les deux ans ça
dépend nous avons une convention
collective de travail qui peut qui peut
être différent par groupe décolle donc
il ya une collectivité il ya une pas
dans une convention collective nationale
mais par exemple pour mona lisa sion à
moi nous avons une différente ce qui
nous permet donc en tant qu'employeur de
pouvoir discerner par rapport à d'autres
la dotation des moyens s'agit aller très
très vite
c'est très simple c'est basé sur le
nombre d'élèves et intérêts des tarifs
différentiel par rapport au type
d'enseignement que vous avez s'est lancé
en professionnel ou bien un enseignement
théorique mais le plus important c'est
que c'est la simplicité et la simplicité
de ce genre de choses ça nous permet de
faire des budgets long terme
en l'occurrence pour notre visa sion des
budgets de rentrer cinq et dix ans à
l'avancé comme hancock comme en france
d'ailleurs le niveau statistique de
qualité statistique est très très haut
donc nous savons maintenant combien
d'enfants dans dix ans il y aura dans
nos écoles mais ce qu'ils sont des
jeunes et donc c'est relativement facile
donc de planifier tout ça donc nous
devons de justifier ça se savoure déjà
été dit c'est un bilan annuel qui est
réglementée nous rapportons sur les ati
activités d'éducation die vite et
financière et cetera et cetera
d'ailleurs les laisse lights vous pouvez
les prendre en sortant comme ça si vous
avez manqué un petit quelque chose vous
pourrez le lire si vous voulez nous
avons du cycle de dévaluations on a
parlé beaucoup ici le premier le premier
tour les cycles d'évaluation sont aussi
bien sur le procès en lui même que sur
les résultats
encore une fois ce qui compte le plus
c'est les résultats ce qui compte ce
sont bien entendu les élèves
est ce que maintenant pour terminer ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que le taux
d'autonomie que que nous avons en tant
que co gameiro d'organisation le même
taux de 9,2 d'autonomie elle est valable
aussi pour les élèves pour les écoles
elles-mêmes
c'est pour ça que je comprenais pas tout
très très très bien le premier la
première discussion ce que si un
proviseur dans une de nos écoles à une
bonne idée eh bien ma foi bien on en
parle un petit peu bon un petit peu plus
que ça on fait très très attention si
pour les élèves c'est important
sii a pas trop trop trop de risques pour
ces élèves là et dès que tout ça la
réponse pour ça est affirmative à bien
on y va et puis voilà la seule chose que
nous faisons c'est de publier les
résultats de façon systématique
je voulais enlever ça merci beaucoup je
crois que cette grande souplesse tient
votre structure aussi pour poursuivre
j'ai demandé à chaque intervenant ça
serait intéressant de réagir à ce qui
vient d'être dit parce que ça c'est la
première partie de la la table ronde
donc avec la mise en lumière
d'expérimentation et puis nous
terminerons la table ronde avec
l'intervention de la présidente de
l'ifrap j'avais présidente excusez moi
mais directeur c'est mieux madame agnès
verdier molinié
donc je donne la parole donc des
interventions courtes s'il vous plaît et
si vous pouvez les articuler avec ce qui
vient d'être dit ça serait intéressant
au recteur marois recteur de créteil
accompagné de monsieur mouillac et
inspecteurs d'académie je vous laisse la
parole oui merci
soit que la nation confie en fait à
notre école trois grandes missions trois
grandes missions vis-à-vis des jeunes
dont la réussite est vraiment notre
finalité à tous or ces trois grandes
missions et sont connus c'est la
transmission des connaissances c'est la
préparation de la une insertion
professionnelle réussie essaie de former
des citoyens responsables et pour
répondre au thème de la table ronde je
reviendrai peut-être après tout à
l'heure sur les deux expériences qui ont
été présentés je crois que très
clairement
ces trois grandes missions nous y
répondons dans le cadre de partenariats
alors de partenariat un peu de deux
types dirais-je d'abord des partenariats
qui sont liées à une coresponsabilité
tout à l'heure vous avez utilisé un
autre terme vous avez parlé de co
propriété avec les parents et les
entreprises moi je parlerais plutôt de
coresponsabilité il ya d'autres types de
partenaires
et puis aussi des partenariats qui sont
liées à une volonté d'ouverture du
système éducatif
on fera une intervention à deux voix et
on essaiera de rester là la quotité de
minutes qui nous a été attribuée à 2 je
dirais en skeet n'est partenariat lié à
une coresponsabilité crois qu'ils sont
de deux types
il ya les partenariats avec les
collectivités territoriales et les
partenariats avec les parents alors
vis-à-vis des collectivités
territoriales le partenariat avec les
communes c'est un partenariat ancien
c'est ce qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure
par monsieur le maire et président du du
2 du regroupement de communes c'est un
partenariat ancien qui découlent du 19e
siècle et je crois qu'ils qui a
l'habitude d'être vécue est géré par les
inspecteurs d'académie par les
inspecteurs de l'éducation nationale
j'ai d'ailleurs remarquer qu'ils
figurent dans votre dans votre comité de
pilotage
ce partenariat avec des collectivités
qui c'est
établie plus récemment pour le second
degré c'est-à-dire les collèges et les
lycées notamment dans le cadre des lois
de décentralisation qui ont été évoquées
ce n'est pas les rappeler il ya eu les
deux actes des lois de décentralisation
sur ces lois de décentralisation et sur
ce partenariat avec les collectivités
devraient évoquer deux thèmes le premier
qui est un thème d'actualité à la fois
pour les collectivités que sont les
conseils régionaux et pour je dirais les
représentants de l'état
actuellement ce sont les contrats de
plan régional pour le développement des
formations professionnelles parce que ça
c'est un thème concret d'actualité de
vie du partenariat pour les dix et avec
les conseils régionaux et je vous
rappelle que normalement avant le 1er
juin de 2 cette année
ces contrats doivent être signés à la
fois par les présidents de conseils
régionaux les préfets et les autorités
académiques et puis au delà de ce que la
loi a confié aux collectivités que ce
soit d'ailleurs pour les communes pour
les régions où pour les départements
c'est vrai que ces collectivités
s'engagent fortement dans d'autres
dossiers
il ya celui des technologies de
l'information et de la communication par
exemple dans lequel on sait que les
régions et les conseils généraux sont
déjà très engagé et dans lequel les
communes que ce soit les communes
d'ailleurs en milieu rural ou en milieu
urbain maintenant s'engage c'est
d'ailleurs à ce titre que pour
l'académie de créteil on a signé avec
l'association des maires d'île de france
une convention récemment pour donner
justement un cadrage au développement de
ces technologies de l'information et de
la communication dans les écoles le
partenariat de co responsabilité avec
les parents là aussi je dirais qu'un
certain nombre de textes ont permis de
redéfinir ses relations de l'école avec
les parents que ce soit au niveau des
conseils de classe au niveau des
conseils d'administration des conseils
d'école mais plein d'autres instances
dans lesquelles les parents participent
je pense par exemple aux commissions
d'appels au comité d'éducation à la
santé et à la citoyenneté d'autres
d'autres instances
au-delà de ces deux types de relations
de partenariat donc encore
responsabilité il ya d'autres
partenariats qui sont importants pour
nous mais qui sont liées à la volonté
d'ouverture du système éducatif sont les
partenariats avec le monde de
l'entreprise et les partenariats avec se
diraient les partenaires des politiques
et du caire
sur le monde de l'entreprise il ya un
partenariat traditionnel qu'est liés par
exemple à la définition des formations
c'est toute la réforme par exemple du
baccalauréat professionnel pour le
passage au baccalauréat professionnel en
trois ans a fait l'objet mais c'était au
niveau national de discussion importante
avec les différentes branches
professionnelles c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que tous les bac pro sont pas passer
tout de suite à trois ans ce partenariat
il est important aussi pour la formation
des élèves au travers des périodes de
formation en entreprise
et puis de la validation et le rôle des
conseillers de l'enseignement
technologique par exemple qui préside
les jurys de diplôme de niveau 5 c'est
quelque chose d'important et c'est
vraiment une marque très là aussi très
concrète de ce partenariat
mais il peut aller au delà il peut aller
au delà avec le développement par
exemple de formation sous statut
d'apprenti dans les établissements
scolaires avec la validation des acquis
de l'expérience qui est un dossier qui
est très important et que là aussi en
concert avec les milieux
socio-économiques et puis le
développement de plateformes de
technologique et puis le deuxième type
de partenariat lié à une volonté
d'ouverture du système éducatif
il est fait avec tout ce que j'appelle
les partenaires 1 2 des politiques
éducatives c'est à dire l'ouverture qui
se reflète dans des conventions qui sont
souvent au niveau d'ailleurs des
départements avec la justice la police
la gendarmerie les mairies les centres
sociaux les conseils généraux que ce
soit pour tout ce qui concerne la
sensibilisation des jeunes aux problèmes
de justice
et ça fait partie de l'éducation à la
citoyenneté que ce soit les référents
police ou gendarmerie qui maintenant
sont assez largement répandu dans l'est
dans les établissements scolaires que ce
soit aussi pour tout un volet qui est
parent qui est difficile mais qui est
tout ce qui concerne les les
signalements et là aussi gars vraiment
des relations qui sont beaucoup
développées dans dans ce domaine et qui
peuvent encore se développer puisque
certains conseils généraux certaines
communes par exemple se sont récemment
engagés sur la prise en charge des et
des exclus temporaires par exemple pour
éviter que ces exclus temporaires et
traînent dans les rues de la ville
il ya certains conseils généraux des
exclusions temporaires d'établissements
il ya des conseils généraux qui au
travers d'associations finance des
programmes pour qu'il soit pris en
charge pendant les périodes d'exclusion
temporaire
donc ça aussi c'est cdd des choses
nouvelles qui se met en place
voilà ce que je voulais dire très
rapidement assurent sur cette ouverture
du système éducatif donc je crois que
par rapport au thème de la table ronde
c'est véritablement le partenariat qui
sous tend notre fonctionnement de notre
école c'est pas toujours facile à bible
partenariat c'est vrai que quand on est
tout seul ça peut peut-être plus plus
évident mais je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui est à la fois irréversible est
indispensable et je crois que pour que
le partenariat fonctionne bien il ya au
moins deux conditions et à la fois le
dialogue mais s'il ya aussi le respect
le respect de chacun des partenaires et
de ses contraintes et c'est comme ça
qu'on aura une éducation qui est une
éducation nationale parce que je crois
que c'est le souhaitent tous mais dans
un cadre partenarial merci deux points
rapides pour compléter l'intervention de
monsieur le recteur un premier point est
un point de vigilance par rapport à ces
partenariats dont on a vu tout l'intérêt
j'aimerais que tu avais une rappeler
qu'ils peuvent avoir
c'est que notamment au niveau des
établissements scolaires les des écoles
nous sommes très largement sollicité par
toute une série d'acteurs qu'ils soient
associatifs qu'ils soient culturels
qu'ils soient sociaux pour intervenir
dans le cadre du temps scolaire et donc
nous nous devons avoir une certaine
vigilance par rapport à toutes ces
sollicitations parce que à force de trop
vouloir multiplier ses interventions sur
temps scolaire nous risquerions s'il n'y
prenons pas garde quel que soit
l'intérêt de ces interventions je ne
remets pas en cause l'intérêt des
interventions nous risquerions de
parfois de ne prendre du temps de classe
or nous nous avons quand même eu un
engagement par rapport à aux élèves et à
leurs parents d'élèves c'est de garantir
le temps d'apprentissage qui est dû aux
élèves
donc il faut vraiment s'assurer parce
que nous avons si on d'intervention nous
assurer de l'intérêt pédagogique de
l'intervention qui nous est proposé
c'est à dire en quoi cette intervention
va t'elle faciliter l'acte pédagogique
et donc améliorer la performance de nos
élèves
donc ça c'est une vigilance qu'on doit
avoir tout le temps j'ai dirigé par
exemple un collège et je me souviens
qu'à avoir fait mis bout-à-bout l'an un
collège dont défavorisé de la banlieue
lilloise et j'avais mis bout-à-bout
l'ensemble des interventions çà
aboutissait à faire qu'il y avait un
tiers de temps de classes en moins ce
qui voulait dire que finalement
l'éducation prioritaire et des données
donner plus mais donnez-moi et
d'enseignement dont je crois qu'on a une
vigilance à avoir par rapport à ces
sollicitations quelles que soient leurs
intérêts le deuxième point est pour
pouvoir dire ce que monsieur venez voir
monsieur le recteur c'est que
effectivement nous sommes sollicités
fortement notamment par les communes par
rapport au développement des outils
informatiques et là ça fait est qu un
petit peu à ce qui été dit précédemment
également 2 lors de la table ronde
précédente c'est à dire que je crois
qu'il ya vraiment ça se passe
globalement dans mon esprit c'est à dire
que on se met vraiment autour d'une
table la commune où la collectivité nous
dit voilà nous on a un investissement
massif a à faire et donc concrètement
aidez nous à faire l'investissement
pertinent d'un point de vue pédagogique
éviter les effets gadgets parce que
parfois l'informatique ça peut être un
effet un peu gadget donc en quoi cela va
se faciliter l'acquisition des
connaissances et donc là on voit bien
que les anciens schémas de partage des
compétences entre l'état et les
collectivités ont très largement sont
très largement dépassé dans l'intérêt de
l'acte pédagogique
voilà je serai pas plus long que ça
merci beaucoup de respecter ce timing je
vais donner la parole maintenant à
monsieur jean monnier qui est première
adjointe à la mairie de scionzier et qui
a mis en place qui va témoigner un
partenariat original encore qu'un autre
acteur local la mairie cette fois je
vous laisse la parole
merci mais on va associer un peu à ce
débat
madame chabrier qui m'accompagnent dans
le cadre du powerpoint qui va diffuser
et monsieur cédric mayol qui est
directeur de l'établissement écoles
élémentaires qui est située sur la
commune puisque moment où on l'a dit
jusqu'à maintenant c'est un travail de
groupe
autant en fête est un moment donné que
les groupes apparaissent j'ai préféré
vous écrire plutôt que parler avec des
propos qui risquent vers lesquels je
risquais de m'envoler qu'à la limite une
soirée maîtrisé en acceptant de
participer à cette table ronde
je n'envisage aucunement de livrer un
modèle d'expérimentation en matière
d'organisation du système scolaire mais
plus modestement de témoigner d'une
expérience locale pouvant éventuellement
enrichir le débat
j'ai le privilège d'exercer des
fonctions d'adjoint délégué aux affaires
sociales et scolaires au sein de la
commune de scionzier petites communes
qui est située vers le pied du
mont-blanc beerlao vers chamonix que je
vous présente en quelques chiffres
sept mille habitants dans une
agglomération de 45000 avec une
progression progression de ge
démographique de l'ordre de 15% sur une
dizaine d'années 20% de logements
sociaux seront parc des résidentiels de
2400 logements un taux de chômage entre
7 et 10%
je préfère vous dire 10 n'est pas en vue
de la validation du 7 mai aujourd'hui
effectivement plus près de 7 23%
population étrangère dont 50 % d'origine
étrangère trois mille trois cents
salariés sur un bassin de 15000 emplois
industriels 150 usines entreprises sur
la commune pour lui n'est cité 1400
élèves scolarisés dans un établissement
scolaire du premier et du second degré
depuis 1995 mais la municipalité a
clairement orienté son action en faveur
de l'enfant et de son éducation
opposants par ailleurs le principe que
tous les facteurs concourant cet
objectif
comme tous les acteurs y participant de
près comme de loin devait être soutenu
sans réserve de l'accomplissement de
leur mission et de leurs obligations
respectives
par suite et fort logiquement la
programmation pluriannuelle des
investissements s'est très vite polarisé
autour de la réhabilitation des groupes
scolaires élémentaires école maternelle
construction d'une crèche l'époque 98
2001 a signé la construction d'un
nouveau groupe scolaire avec
restauration sont de loisirs associés
et pour un montant de l'ordre de trois
millions et demi d'euros la période 2002
2010 s'est consacré 1 quand elle est la
réhabilitation par tranches successives
d'un groupe élémentaire
je vous passe les détails à 480 élèves
c'est le plus gros centre qui assurent
le secteur vin une salle de classe
je vous donne simplement le montant de
l'ardoisé il est 12 millions d'euros
un projet de cette envergure n'était
concevable et viable qu'à deux
conditions un effort budgétaire hors
normes et sans doute plus encore la mise
en oeuvre d'une réelle et constante
concertation avec le corps enseignant
les parents d'élèves le personnel
communal et plus généralement tous les
acteurs de l'éducation scolaire et
périscolaire à la faveur de cette
expérience je serais tenté d'affirmer
une sorte de travailler ensemble inédit
s'est progressivement installée entre
leurs représentants locaux et
l'éducation nationale et la municipalité
la stabilité des personnels et des
équipes politique
on a déjà un peu parlé mais également
des praticiens municipaux a conforté les
échanges et permis une meilleure
connaissance mais aussi une
compréhension plus aisé de l'autre
l'évolution de la méthodologie adoptée
avec le traitement des problématiques
sociales impulsées par la politique de
la ville dans le cadre du contrat urbain
de cohésion sociale a de fait produits
ces dernières années un pas à ce
partenariat une rare richesse une
transcription au secteur éducatif n'en a
été que plus aisés et notamment permet
d'assurer le déploiement plus les sorts
puis l'essor du programme de réussite
éducative l'enfant son éducation et son
environnement logement ressources santé
plus partie éducative ambitionne bien
d'une prise en charge globale des
problématiques sociales familiales
éducatives
la réponse ne peut que ne peut excuser
moi que tendre vers la
pluridisciplinarité et suggérer des
partenariats multiples dans des secteurs
multiples ainsi sur cette commune
le social réunit le ccs et assistants
sociaux le conseil général les
associations caritatives et familiale le
logement mais sur une conception
systématique avec le principal bailleur
social pour réaliser une politique de
peuplement concertée garantir la mixité
sociale ou bien encore contribuer au
règlement des problèmes d'endettement
entre parenthèses l'éducatif privilégié
naturellement un dialogue
avec des enseignants leur hiérarchie
ainsi que les représentations de lait
des représentants de la société par an
d'élèves l'emploi et l'orientation
rhénus en un lieu unique les permanences
de pôle emploi mission locale jeunes et
maison de l'emploi chacun de ces
ensembles partenariaux est à même de
dialoguer à tout instant avec tout ou
partie de notre ensemble grâce à
l'interface communal l'éducation
nationale par exemple peut interpeller
les ccs sur la situation financière
d'une famille la formation sera
immédiatement relayée auprès de
l'assistante sociale voire auprès du
bailleur ainsi que la grande majorité
des cas des solutions rapides et
pérennes sont en fait mis en place pour
ce faire il y a des partenaires un
partenariat direct
et puis un partenariat indirecte le
partenaire direct ces deux postes
d'agents municipaux mis à disposition
entièrement sur l'école élémentaire du
château de l'école de monsieur cédric
mayol avec des missions qui sont des
missions d'accompagnement de la
direction et d'autre des missions
d'accompagnement de l'ensemble des
enseignants postes d'assistants
d'éducation apporter aux enseignants et
aux élèves un soutien dans leurs rôles
dans les domaines tels que
l'informatique les sorties pédagogiques
les études surveillées intervention
directe sur le quartier du projet
n'oublions pas je voulais pas dis qu'on
a quand même quelque part un chantier
d'un quartier dit sensible qu'on est en
zone dès qu'une d'éducation prioritaire
et qu'on ait effectivement niveau 2 dans
le cadre de la politique de la ville
mais aussi dans la surveillance et les
sorties d'école lien avec l'adulte au
relais en poste dans les transports
scolaires pour faire la médiation auprès
des listes quant au partenariat
indirects eh bien nous avons deux étapes
en mairie les étapes ce tout le monde
sait ce que c'est qu'ils interviennent
au sein des écoles pour des modules ski
natation sport en général on en parlé un
petit peu du sport auto une formatrice
fle français langue étrangère est mise à
disposition du collège pour renforcer
les postes fle dans le cas d'actions
concernant les primes orient et par
ailleurs sur une soutien
sociolinguistique auprès des mères de
famille le trois quarts du temps je
crois qu'aujourd'hui de mémoire il veut
y avoir quarante neuf personnes sur 49
mère de famille qui rentre dans le
collège avec un petit un petit cahier
sous le bras eh bien j'aimerais vous
dire que quand elles en sortent elles
ont pas tout à fait la même allure que
quand elles sortent d'une cave d'un
quartier dans lequel on a fait une
formation d'alphabétisation des
activités périscolaires coordonnée par
le service animation de la mairie en
étroite relation avec le directeur pour
ne pas interférer avec l'accompagnement
éducatif indicatif éducation nationale
le coup de pouce est heureux énorme le
coup de pouce le programme de réussite
éducative à l'école et le soutien de la
politique sociale de notre commune si ce
pea re disparaît je vous en ai parlé
monsieur le sénateur tout le système
risque de s'effondrer
je le sais envahi par et puisque on peut
toujours s'attendre à un moment donné à
disparition des budgets qui s'y
rapportent
mais aujourd'hui sachant que pour 25
familles en difficultés identifiées dans
le cadre du pee sur une école ce mayol
où le coupé si je fais une bêtise sur
une école élémentaire le budget et qui
est accroché et 200000 euros par les
services de l'état environ ces euro ont
tendance à diminuer parce que je crois
que ils ont bien baissé dernièrement et
60000 euros de la part de la commune
donc ses 160 mille euros 25 gamin bon
sachant qu'après ces a des questions à
poser ou pour les poser aux directeurs
et il vous dira effectivement quel est
le retard qu'on a pu combler sur ses
enfants
et quel niveau ils ont atteint je vais
vous demander de vierge ce qu'ils ont
mais vous savez on revient de tellement
loin que non je remercie en même temps
de l'éducation nationale pour le
maintien de cette classe passerelle à
l'école maternelle dû creuser c'est
pareil lacasse passerelle c'est des
enfants de moins de 3 ans à l'intérieur
de ces familles il ya des parents qui
sont en difficulté des difficultés de
langage aujourd'hui tintin et milou
quand il est lui à l'école mais bien de
tintin et milou quand c'est la maman qui
est d'origine
de je ne sais trop où qui va le lire
c'est plus tintin et milou donc on a
intérêt à ce qu effectivement les
parents fréquentent l'établissement
on discute sur la mule mêmes bases et
qu'à ce moment là
l'histoire soit la même l'enfant est
peut-être moins perturbé voilà et puis
je vous passe le reste puisque après les
bénéfices sous couvert d'une charte de
confidentialité direct vous le savez
tous comment donner tous astreints à des
chars de confidentialité mais sachez que
j'ai abandonné aux avait autour de la
table comme on a une trentaine de
personnes qui ont ça dans les tripes qui
ont envie d'avancer et qui ont
effectivement les problèmes en pleine
face eh bien il n'y a pas de raison pour
ne pas y arriver ça veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il faille pas audités ça veut
dire porte pour autant qu'il ne faille
pas virer des actions qui effectivement
non pas le lors de l'audit eu le
résultat escompté
et puis comme disait monsieur mayol
encore propre et arrière des billets des
actions qui qui sont là et qui sont
valides pour une année et puis après
qu'ils n'ont pas devenir pérenne parce
qu'elles ont répondu à une attente à
l'instant t
voilà je vous remercie pour votre écoute
et votre attention et jamais merci pour
cette intervention qui souligne encore
une fois la nécessité de l'évaluation je
crois qu'on vous avez dit audit mais on
tourne autour de cette idée
alors pour finir cette table ronde
les parties prenantes quels sont les
parents d'élèves
encore une fois avec jean jacques hazan
représente la fcpe vous avez vous êtes
déjà intervenu tout à l'heure donc là
encore je vais être très vilaine et vous
demander de faire cours voilà je vous
écoute oui je voudrais d'abord je vais
parler du coi et du comment puis je
voudrais parler du pourquoi en fait au
départ le pourquoi c'est pour faire
réussir les élèves que l'on doit
considérer aujourd'hui que notre
fonctionnement éducatif n'est pas
suffisant ça veut pas dire que cela ne
marche pas ça veut dire que ce n'est pas
suffisant parce que les 85 % d'une
classe d'âge au bac 50 % un bac +3 et
pas de sorties sans qualification est
très loin d'être atteint
et si on se re fixe ça comme objectif on
doit essayer d'organiser les
convergences qui existe entre différents
acteurs publics pour arriver à ce type
de résultats pour arriver à ce résultat
comment ben il ya des expérimentations
et puis il ya quand même un certain
nombre de choses qui doivent nous faire
nous faire réfléchir sur quoi par
exemple d'abord par exemple on va partir
du début petite enfance et maternelle
ont un rapport de l' ocde tout à fait
récemment sorti montre que plus les
collectivités interviennent dans la
petite enfance plus on génère de
l'égalité au travail entre hommes et
femmes
plus cela permet jusqu'au la rizza sion
précoce bien évidemment et et du
résultat
peut-être que si nous avons affirmé ses
objectifs
nous devrions investir plus dans la
petite enfance et quand je dis petite
enfance je veux bien parler toutes
catégories accueille dans des centres de
petite enfance mais aussi école
maternelle or depuis de nombreuses
années les dépenses publiques ont
largement augmenté en termes de petite
enfance
et pourtant le service rendu est plus
réduit j'en veux pour simplement
illustration le rapport de la cour des
comptes à ses récents sur le fait que
ben bien que toutes les collectivités
municipales
les municipalités ont créé un nombre
incalculable de places en crèche et ben
le nombre de postes le nombre de places
en école maternelle a tellement diminué
que finalement on a dépensé beaucoup
plus mais on accueille beaucoup moins
deuxième élément c'est sur la
sectorisation alors là pour le coup on a
et d'expérimentation on en avait avant
surtout et puis on a joué un peu à
l'apprenti sorcier
on savait puisque on savait déjà qu à
paris il n'y avait pas de sectorisation
dans les lycées on savait exactement ce
que ça avait donné une hiérarchisation
des établissements et puis on a dit on
va quand même essayer c'est sûrement
très très bien bien évidemment sans
réflexion avec les collectivités
territoriales et puis finalement on se
retourne vers eux en leur disant
maintenant comment est ce que vous allez
mailler le territoire fermer un certain
nombre d'établissements regrouper revoir
les choses dans une perspective où par
ailleurs vont sont attendus quand même
au collège dans les quatre ans qui
viennent deux cent mille élèves
supplémentaires jeu ça c'est que de la
démographie comme l'a dit en précisant
intervenants ça fait un petit moment
qu'on le sait ça fait même onze ans
puisqu'il arrive à 11 ans et c'est en
2000 qui sont nés les premiers et ça a
pas bougé d'ailleurs on se félicite que
ça augmente toujours un que le nombre de
naissances augmente troisième succès
dans la gestion des moyens dévolus aux
établissements heures postes etc etc je
pense que il est nécessaire si on veut
réfléchir un partenariat bien compris
que les projets et les moyens qui sont
afférents puisse être plus stabilisée ne
pas être remis en cause
pour une raison ou une autre à chaque
fois et que quand on incite à des
regroupements d'établissements que ça
soit de passer d'un rpi à un
regroupement en physique ou que ça soit
des fusions d'établissements genre
collège qui cette réflexion est les
lieux d'abord qu'elle ait lieu d'abord
au niveau du territoire qu'elle ait lieu
aussi en impliquant les familles les
gens les habitants parce que bien
évidemment on va atteindre au territoire
et non pas simplement à l'éducation
nationale
et pourtant aujourd'hui c'est les postes
de l'éducation nationale qui
prédétermine toute sa part à la
discussion préalable mais le résultat
les collectivités territoriales ont
depuis un certain nombre d'années
énormément investi dans l'école et sont
allés bien au-delà de leurs prérogatives
en 90 la dépense intérieure d'éducation
qui étaient entre 6 et demi et qui
allait vers sète et demi pour cent
plutôt à 7% de pib
aujourd'hui elle n'est qu'à six et demi
comme en 1981 je rappelle juste les
collectivités territoriales les penseurs
à peu près 15 % un petit peu moins de 15
% de la dépense et a apporté un peu
moins de 15 % de la dépense d'éducation
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 25
l'état s'étant largement désengager
puisqu'il est passé d'un peu plus de 60
à un petit peu plus de 50% les
collectivités territoriales peuvent pas
être considérés que comme des payeurs ou
comme des appliques en de règles ou de
textes de loi qui sortent mais peut-être
pas directement sur la réussite scolaire
par exemple service minimum d'accueil
c'est pas très engageant ou ou encore là
des questions sur l'absentéisme mais je
vais pas aller là dessus collectivités
territoriales serait censé être
responsable de ça il ya une autre un
autre moyen d'aborder les choses et par
exemple sur les questions de bien-être à
l'école on voit bien aussi qu'il doit y
avoir de la coopération par exemple sur
le mal de dos le mal de dos une dépense
énorme en termes de santé publique
pour autant les cartables des enfants
sont toujours très lourd
il y a pourtant des départements qui ont
déjà investi qui ont mis en place des
oui aux pays-bas comporte pas les
cartables de 20 % du poids du corps mais
nous chez nous oui on vous fera peur
plus sûrement d'autres fois ce n'est pas
que moi et pourtant bien évidemment une
collaboration bien comprise entre des
collectivités territoriales qui pourrait
abonder et réfléchir à une un travail à
faire venir des intervenants extérieurs
exemple décliné sur des postures des
positions des choses comme ça l'état qui
pourrait lui même abondé les manuels
règlerait quand même en partie ce
problème il ya bien évidemment une
question de mobilier qui se posent aussi
sur le dernier objet c'est les rythmes
scolaires
je vais pas re développer vous m'avez
déjà largement entendu sur le sujet vous
me retrouver sur internet quand vous
voulez sur le sur le sujet mais c'est
évident si la seule chose qu'on demande
aux collectivités territoriales c'est
nous on a décidé vous vous appliquez
vous vous débrouillez avec vos rtt que
vous avez négocié pendant six mois et
vous changez tout comme ça du jour au
lendemain au 1er septembre
ça marche très très mal c'est très mal
pris et surtout quand on s'aperçoit que
c'est très mauvais pour les élèves
il serait temps
que l'éducation nationale fasse ce que
les parlementaires ont suggéré alors
comment décloisonner 3 3 3 4 points la
première chose c'est les bars à lait par
an c'est pas des partenaires des parents
je vous rappelle qu'ils font
s'ils sont parties prenantes rey membre
à part entière de la communauté
éducative
ça veut dire qu'ils sont qu'aux
éducateurs que la question n'est pas de
leur faire faire la même chose que les
enseignants parce que les devoirs c'est
très gentil mais cette sous traitance
pédagogique aux familles s'adresse à des
gens qui sont des très très mauvais sous
traitants et donc il faut surtout pas
faire ça il faut réfléchir et travailler
avec eux pour la réussite de leur aide
de leurs enfants leur donner les moyens
de faire le travail qu'ils font chez eux
et par exemple pour apprendre à lire moi
chez moi il ya des bouteilles d'eau avec
des trucs marqué même si c'est des
marques c'est pas très grave et plein
d'autres choses où il ya des éléments à
faire lire des panneaux dans les rues et
là effectivement ce qui est fait en
classe en termes pédagogiques avec une
autre chose peut être fait de manière
très complémentaire à la maison il y à
d'autres complémentarités sur les
collectivités territoriales je les dis
mais il ya une complémentarité un peu
spécial que je vous le soulevait
aujourd'hui en vous remerciant de se
coller de ce colloque c'est le
partenariat entre la réflexion de
l'éducation nationale à l'éducation
nationale et celle des politiques qui le
font aujourd'hui
c'est un peu bizarre mais c'est quand
même très très vrai dans l'appart le
partenariat avec les parents mais aussi
avec une communauté de vie il ya les
partenariats avec le quartier dans un
récent rapport sur les collèges
oui c'est évident il y a des difficultés
dans les collèges il y a des difficultés
de deux passerelles entre la vie dans le
collège et la vie en dehors du collège
ça génère beaucoup de difficultés
beaucoup de peurs et ce rapport entre le
collège de son quartier car nous sommes
attachés à cette sectorisation qui
existe quand même toujours un peu cela
le rapport de la population avec le
collège de son quartier c'est son
rapport avec l'école et il faut qu'il y
ait beaucoup plus de partenariat est
beaucoup plus de porosité et que la
porte ne puisse être franchie dernière
chose pour arriver à ça aussi il ya un
petit décloisonnement interne c'est que
si on arrivait un peu à mieux organisés
et entre leurs postes et heures
supplémentaires pour améliorer le
fonctionnement du remplacement on
n'aurait peut-être pas besoin d'avoir un
partenariat avec pôle emploi
dernière chose c'est eux oui c'est il
est nécessaire pour obtenir ça pour un
autre sens deux choses la première c'est
que tous ces partenariats il se gère
avec des humains et c'est humain sont
des enseignants et des chefs
d'établissement et pour ça il faut
redévelopper une vraie formation des
enseignants et la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il ya des électeurs dont on ne parle
que très rarement et dont j'ai déjà
parlé à la dernière fois c'est les
inspecteurs de circonscription
il me semble qu'il ya une colonne
vertébrale nécessaire pour la mise en
place de projets de mise en cohérence
entre des projets d'école des projets de
collèges axée sur la réussite de tous
les élèves et l'acquisition du socle
commun et ce qu'ils peuvent faire ça ce
sont des inspecteurs de circonscription
qui sont d'ailleurs déjà chef
d'établissement qui donne l'unité à
chacun et puis une cohérence d'ensemble
merci merci jean ollivro cas vous êtes
secrétaire général d'aï qui est le
syndicat des personnels administratifs
alors vous est pris entre la
collectivité et l'état compte me
retrouve
voilà pour les raisons qu'on connaît il
nous reste très peu de temps donc plutôt
que de déroulée l'intervention peut être
vous pourriez nous répondre sur la
question suivante sur l'acte iii de la
décentralisation parce que pour vous ça
se pose en ces termes et je pense que ça
intéressera la l'assemblée en termes de
partenariats de décloisonnement comment
vous vivez les choses vous personnel y
être
entre ces deux entités que sont l'état
et collectivités
j'aurais du mal à répondre sur l'acte
iii ce qui a priori il n'est pas encore
finalisé il est en cours bien il ya un
certain nombre de réflexions
ce que je sais en tout cas c'est que il
faut quand même qu'on parte d'un minimum
de deux définitions au service public
d'éducation du partenariat
enfin du cloisonnement au partenariat
moi je suis partie simplement de la loi
quand même du 13 août 2004
je vais comme la lire ses cours
l'éducation est un service public
national dans l'organisation le
fonctionnement sont assumés par l'état
sous réserve des compétences attribuées
par le présent code de l'éducation
un comité territorial pour les associer
au développement de ce service public
cette définition d'ailleurs rejoint
peut-être je n'allais pas dire les états
d'âme et les quelques interrogations
développé par le recteur de grenoble ce
matin on voit bien la dissymétrie alors
au delà il ya quelque chose qui est
oubliée qui lie depuis ce matin c'est
qu'il ya quand même un établissement
scolaire où se rencontrent les 2 et qu'à
un moment donné passé au partenariat si
aussi quelque part sortir du discours et
contractualiser sur trois niveaux
état collectivités et à établissements
et collectivités établissements
bref l'établissement est quand même au
centre est cet organisme de sens que si
c'est pour arriver aux équipes et des
pédagogies qu'on s'est fixés alors dans
ce cadre là il ya eu une étude
intéressante du conseil d'état je vais
pas être très long qui a été publiée au
mois d'août 2010 sur les établissements
publics et qui indique aussi que
l'établissement public dispose d'une
plasticité certaine pour répondre les
objectifs différents nous venons
d'horizons différents alors à partir de
là je crois que si l'établissement est
effectivement le
l'unité de base de notre service public
pour répondre aux différents objectifs
fixés par la nation il faut déjà
peut-être au-delà de la conquête de la
contractualisation construire aussi sur
l'autonomie on le voit à travers les
universités par exemple il peut pas y
avoir d'autonomie d'établissement si on
ne fut pas une vraie gouvernance une
équipe de direction
alors moi je suis frappé quand même
devoir nous avons organisé avec nos amis
du snpden
un colloque à fin 2010 sur les 25 ans
dans le pays
il a fallu attendre quand même le 25e
anniversaire de le pe pour que nos deux
organisations syndicales qui ont poussé
on débouche sur un concept que tout le
monde trouvait normal n'existait pas
dans le code de l'éducation
une équipe de direction avec un chef
tablissements entouré de cadres dont un
cadre administratif et qui est
l'interlocuteur l'interlocuteur je dis
bien des qualités de rattachement alors
je sais qu'il faut répondre à votre
question qu'il ya des interrogations sur
faut-il ou non décentralisée l'intendant
on pas pour aller vite puisque j'ai pas
le temps je dirais que l'intendant n'a
pas seulement qu'on fonction une
fonction d'agent chef il est bien le
cadre administratif qui aux côtés du
chef d'établissement
eh ben le seconde dans toutes les tâches
administratives matérielles et
financières qui englobe aussi bien ce
qui vient de l'état que ce qui vient des
collectivités et je crois que le
démembrement de le pe n'est pas
forcément la solution pour mieux
construire le service public voyage je
serai pas plus long merci parfait pour
conclure donc je laisse la parole à la
directrice de l'ifrap
qui va nous donner son regard sur les
débats que vous nous devons nous venons
d'avoir sur c'est la contractualisation
la place des collectivités dans cette
âme éducatif donc moi je vais apporter
quelques chiffres d'abord je voulais
remercier la mission pour son invitation
intervenir rapplique la fondation ifrap
est une fondation d'utilité publique qui
évalue les politiques publiques comme ce
qu'elle est c'est à dire un think tank
avec une vision donc très très extérieur
puisque nous n'avons que des
financements privés donc voilà donc on
essaie d'apporter un peu plus au débat
en essayant d'utiliser tous les chiffres
disponibles
et là je vais vous faire part d'une
d'une recherche qu'on est en train de
réaliser donc et pas complètement encore
abouti mais dont je pense que les
chiffres pourront peut-être ouvrir
quelques perspectives dans ce débat
d'abord on est parti en fait de l'idée à
savoir est ce qu'il ya une comparaison
des coûts par élève et par an entre le
public et le privé en france et on s'est
rendu compte qu'il n'y avait rien qui
qui existait et que finalement même la
cour des comptes ou le ministère n'avait
jamais publié comme vraiment en
agrégeant toutes les dépenses de l'état
des collectivités des parents et des
entreprises par élève et par an ce qu'on
dépense et donc on a essayé de faire ce
travail en partant des chiffres du
ministère et en les agrégeant donc ces
chiffres c'est des chiffres repères et
références statistiques qu'on appelle
reste donc toutes les sources sont des
sources de chiffre officiel mais qui
n'ont jamais été mis en perspective de
la façon dont je voulais je vais vous
les présenter donc je crois qu'il ya un
postulat de départ qu'on peut poser
c'est que on peut pas dire que le privé
ou le public on est vraiment meilleur
résultat à l'un ou l'autre en terme de
par exemple de réussite au bac ou quoi
que ce soit en tout cas y'a pas vraiment
on peut pas dire le privé est meilleur
ou le public est meilleur on peut dire
vont ils sont semblables ils sont
comparables
enfin j'ai pas si je pose ce postulat
peut-être certains seront pas d'accord
mais en tout cas ce qui apparaît dans
les chiffres que vous présente dans ce
premier slide c'est que pour
l'enseignement du premier degré donc que
ce soit collectivités ou état ou avait
en intégrant les dépenses des ménages en
intégrant les dépenses des entreprises
dans le public pour un élève du premier
degré et par an on dépense 5469 euro par
an quand on regarde la dépense
comparable pour le privé on est à 3443
euros donc on a une différence de 2026
euros je pose ses chiffres sur la table
bien conscience que après découvrir un
écart pareil
ensuite si on peut se poser des
questions de où ça vient et j'ai pas
encore toutes les explications possibles
mais en tout cas pour un élève du
premier degré on a cet écart de 2000
euros par élève et par an globalement en
france on a fait le même calcul donc y
aidant dans ce slide présenté ici pour
le second degré on a pour le public une
dépense globale collective de 9900 89
euros et pour le priver de 7200 un euro
donc là encore on trouve plus de 2500
euros d'écart 2007 188 euros exactement
d'écart entre public et privé pour le
second degré
donc ça nous semble énorme
alors il faut bien souligner qu on a
déduit de tout ça enfin les dépenses
d'administration ne sont pas calculés
dedans on est d'accord il ya à peu près
4 millions 4 milliards et quelque part
dans 4 milliards et quelques dépenses
d'administration qui sont pas intégrés
dans ces chiffres
mais on pourra avoir un débat sur ce
site met donc vraiment on découvre là
un écart important il faut souligner
quand même que dans ces chiffres que je
vous présente au global par élève et par
an on a bien les dépenses
d'investissement qui sont comprises
dedans 1 donc ça c'est important
je le souligne parce qu'on n'a pas
forcément on aurait aimé faire là là là
comparaisons globales hors
investissements et je vais vous montrer
qu'on peut le faire pour les
départements mais on n'a pas pu le faire
au global par élève et par an donc là
les les investissements sont récents
sont intégrés dans dans ce coup mais il
n'empêche que trouver un écart de 2000 à
2500 euros par élève et par an nous
semble énorme et on ne comprend pas tout
à l'heure je crois que claude thélot
disait qu'on faisait pas assez de
comparaison public privé je crois qu'il
faudrait qu'on mette en place des
indicateurs beaucoup plus fin et en tout
cas je comprends pas que dans le cadre
par exemple de la loge de la loi
organique des lois de finances on n'est
pas mis en place ces indicateurs de
court bien coûter un élève dans le
public ou dans le privé de façon globale
et de façon comparable
ça je me tourne un peu vers les
instances responsables de cela mais je
ne vois pas pourquoi on n'a pas ces
indicateurs
ensuite bien sûr nous on se fonde pas
sur une comparaison la pédagogie ou quoi
que ce soit on est uniquement sur sur
des chiffres et sur le coup donc pour
passer au second slide
voilà là on a une comparaison par région
public privé donc vous avez à gauche la
dépense moyenne par lycéens de
l'enseignement public par région et là
encore malheureusement pour les régions
on n'a pas pu distinguer les 10 des
dépenses de fonctionnement et
d'investissement donc on est à la fois
sur le fonctionnement et sur
investissement et vous voyez que là
aussi à quelque chose d'assez étonnant
donc à gauche bien sûr le public et à
droite le privé alors ce qu'il plus
étonnant c'est qu'on
on a du mal à comprendre comment se
décide finalement le niveau de dépense
parce que voyez qu'il ya des des régions
qui dépensent plus de 4000 euros par
élève et par an notamment le limousin
l'auvergne le languedoc-roussillon la
haute normandie et en parallèle parfois
c'est même département et je vais
prendre l'exemple du limousin le
limousin plus de 4000 euros par élève
est pas rendu public et vous voyez dans
la carte de droite que pour
l'enseignement privé
il est au contraire à moins de 700 euros
par élève et par an voilà donc ensuite
on a du mal à expliquer comment se font
les choix politiques pour arriver à de
telles disparités par région par élève
et par an et entre public et privé
ensuite comme je vous dis on est en
train de réfléchir sur quelles peuvent
être les origines de ces disparités et
toutes les bonnes volontés sont
bienvenues pour trouver des explications
mais il nous semble
on parlait tout à l'heure d'une
éducation très centralisé il nous semble
qu'il ya des choses qui sont très
centralisé et puis aussi des normes de
dépenses qui sont totalement laxiste et
laisser un peu à la discrétion des
décideurs soient soient locaux mais
aussi il ya aussi des écarts nationaux
mais voilà donc on se pose des questions
là dessus et tout à l'heure monsieur des
pays-bas vous expliquez que vous avez un
tarif par élève et
et j'aurais aimé savoir si ce tarif par
élève il était normalisé parce que non
vous dites que c'est par type
d'enseignement ensuite qu'à une
différence peut-être on pourrait avoir
cette discussion ensuite après mon
intervention parce que je trouve que il
ya peut-être une réflexion à avoir sur
comment on en arrive à des écarts pareil
je vais en venir au dernier slide de
comparaison des défunts les dépenses de
fonctionnement alors là on n'est que sur
le fonctionnement pour les départements
on a réussi à isoler ce qui est de
l'investissement mais malheureusement là
on peut pas faire la comparaison public
privé donc
là je vous livre et
la carte de france avec qui montre que
d'un département à l'autre
le fic le fonctionnement peut être très
très hétérogène et notamment on peut on
peut souligner par exemple que le le
cheikh dépenses en 2008 1478 euros par
élève et par an et le département voisin
et à 375 euros
donc ça on est d'accord que c'est donc
c'est le loir et cher à 375 euros par
élève et par an par rapport aux chairs
qui est à 1478 euros par élève et par an
donc là on parle on parle des collèges
voilà donc il faut peut-être se poser
des questions sur la peut-être la
décentralisation on a on a souvent
évoqué tout à l'heure la question
effectivement dans certains pays et la
france est vraisemblablement le pays le
plus centralisés dans sa gestion de
l'éducation peut-être pas le plus mais
mais voilà la question de s que la
décentralisation se fait sur des
critères qui sont cohérents et je
rappellerai que dans le dernier rapport
de l' ocde sur son étude économique de
la france 2011 l' ocde rappelle que la
décentralisation a sans doute conduit à
des pertes et d'économies d'échelle par
exemple fait d'avoir donné aux régions
la responsabilité des lycées au
département celles des collèges a sans
doute augmenté des dépenses publiques
là où les deux établissements sont
situés sur le même site géographique en
raison de problèmes de coordination
entre la région et le département
la clause générale de compétence aussi
qu'ils avaient parfois été évoqué comme
étant
une potentielle réforme de la réforme
des collectivités qui fait que
l'éducation n'est pas traitée par un
seul échelon mais qu'on le retrouve les
régions les départements et les communes
et peut-être quelque chose qu'il faut
questionner en tout cas l'oscd eux
visiblement se pose aussi la question
parce que ces économies d'échelle
elle se peuvent se faire aussi dans une
gestion qui à la fois peut-être et plus
efficiente et là on se place quand même
dans un contexte de dépenses publiques
et de déficit qui est qui est quand même
assez difficile pour la france en ce
moment la situation des finances
publiques n'est pas aisé et il me semble
que les chiffres que nous découvrons à
la fondation ifrap de cet écart entre
public et privé peuvent permettre de re
réfléchir comment ça se fait qu'on
arrive à éduquer un élève l'emmener
jusqu'au bac dans le privé pour autant
d'argent en moins j'ai pas fait le
calcul d'ailleurs si on compte un élève
qui pourrait bien passer de 3 ans à à 18
ans dans le dans le système privé par
rapport au système public
quel est le surcoût public mais je
poserai juste deux ou trois questions
en conclusion elle ce qui aurait pas des
bonnes pratiques du privé dont on
pourrait s'inspirer
est ce que la règle du 80 20
la règle du 80/20 qui dit qu' on a 80 %
pour le public et 20% pour le privé est
ce qu'il faut pas la redéfinir la
question aussi d'expérimentation on a
parlé beaucoup d'expérimentation est-ce
qu'on peut pas envisager la gestion de
collège ou de lycée aussi en délégation
de service public
donc ça ce sont des questions peut-être
que d'autres pays se sont se sont déjà
posés et donc je repose la question de
la clause générale de compétence de
compétences des collectivités mais aussi
celle de la transparence parce que la
question de ces indicateurs de coûts
public-privé mériterait peut-être que
par exemple la cour des comptes
se penche dessus peut-être en
partenariat avec le ministère de
l'éducation et réfléchissent aussi à
d'où viennent ces écarts parce que nous
n'avons pas les réponses là dessus
sachant qu'il faut bien souligner que
dans les chiffres que je vous ai soumis
notamment le premier tableau avec le
premier slide il y a bien sûr les
dépenses des parents qui sont comprises
dedans je tiens à le souligner un donc
ses dépenses de par des parents comprise
donc voilà parce que parfois on peut
dire mais si le privé finalement ce sont
les parents qui paie etc
non on essaie de comparer vraiment ce
qui est comparable
quel est le devenir de cette étude et
quel est ce que vous l'avez présenté au
ministère de l'éducation nationale
comment vous voyez la suite
alors on est en échange un peu là dessus
mais plutôt de façon officieuse avec le
ministre avec le ministère mais voilà
ensuite on prévoit potentiellement une
publication
mais il faut d'abord que je vous dis
encore je vous livre cette étude qui
n'est pas encore totalement terminée on
est sur une réflexion bien sûr on n'est
pas accroché par exemple pourquoi
arrêter tout de suite on n'est pas
accroché à l'idée que parlant ce soit
2000 euros ou 1500 euros voyez ce que je
veux dire l'idée c'est de dire il ya un
écart il existe un écart de combien il
exactement
et d'où il vient cet écart est comment
est ce que on peut se poser la question
de finalement quelle est l'efficacité ne
dépense que l efficience sur ce ne sont
pas des gros mots ce sont des questions
que tous les pays se posent sur la
performance de leurs dépenses publiques
et dans le système d'éducation je crois
que c'est particulièrement pertinent
parce que c'est un un service public
auquel sont très attachés bien sûr
l'ensemble des français je crois que
votre intervention pour l'art est
articulée avec le thème de la table
ronde de la journée montre bien qu'en
terme de contractualisation de plus de
décentralisation d'intervention des
collectivités
la question finale c'est
est-ce que l'éducation restera nationale
si ce qu'elle est déjà dans l'équité des
dépenses dans le budget par élève enfin
vous pointez je pense des questions
essentielles qui ont été posées par les
uns et les autres mais bon en tout cas
on est très intéressés par le devenir de
cette étude bon mais je le retiens
et je passe la parole pour conclure
cette matinée
alors sauf si vous me laissez un peu de
temps supplémentaire
je pense que sur l'étude du toit il doit
y avoir des questions vous disiez me
suis faut arrêter tout de suite
donc est ce que vous vouliez non mais
moi je crois que non alors je laisse la
priorité à la salle est ce qu'il ya des
interventions dans la salle et combien à
peu près pour qu'on puisse calibré et on
passera en finira sur mes interventions
des tables rondes alors je vois deux
interventions une devant trois
interventions
madame vous pouvez vous présenter vous
aussi madame chainel président de
l'association de l'union nationale des
associations autonomes de parents
d'élèves
donc je voulais réagir en tant que
parents d'élèves sur le partenariat dont
on a parlé tout au courant tout au long
de cette matinée
j'ai souvent entendu parler de deux
partenariats entre rectorat
collectivités et ministère un petit peu
de temps en temps de partenariat avec
les parents heureusement monsieur dubois
vous avez souligné un bon partenariat
sur votre projet dans le nord où les
parents étaient intégrés dans la somme
par don intégré au projet semble-t-il
depuis la base du projet ce qui est une
excellente façon de d'amener les parents
à accepter une nouveauté qui au départ
sûrement leur faisait peur et je pense
que dans beaucoup de projets si les
parents étaient associés vraiment à la
base du projet on aurait beaucoup plus
de choses positives qui se passerait un
peu partout dans le territoire
ça c'est une première chose et donc je
ne reviendrai pas là-dessus mais je
pense que le partenariat parents vous
l'avez tous compris nous le réclamons
encore plus qu'il n'existe à l'heure
actuelle
et puis je veux juste à dire un mot sur
la question des coûts que je viens
d'entendre équipe en tant que parent
d'élève me choque profondément que ce
soit un enseignement privé ou public
je suis je défends les élèves de
l'enseignement public mais je ne vois
pas le il pour moi le coût d'un enfant
dans l'enseignement ne doit pas être
déterminée selon public ou le privé
mais selon l'investissement à long terme
de l'éducation de nos enfants et c'est
un investissement national qu'il passe
par différents biais à la limite peu
importe mais c'est vraiment
l'investissement national que l'on veut
consacrer à l'éducation de nos enfants
qui deviendront les dégâts les
partenaires plus tard de toute là de
toute notre pays qui doit être le plus
important donc le coup à mon avis en
tant que parents d'élèves doit passer en
second plan je sais qu évidemment pour
les politiques ça ne peut pas être la
même chose mais en tant que parent c'est
un petit peu choquant d'entendre parler
de coût par enfant on a parlé souvent
mais à chaque fois j'ai cette réaction
d'être assez blessé dans dans le sens où
considère nos enfants comme un peu une
marchandise et et quand même ça n'est
pas la même chose
voilà je m'arrête merci attention
monsieur au fond 3
et puis on terminera avec monsieur
première oui bonjour laurent escure
secrétaire national du syndicat des
enseignants unsa
je voulais juste réagir brièvement par
rapport à l'étude qui vient d'être
présentée parce que vous posiez la
question du devenir de l'étude
je pense qu'elle mériterait d'être plus
complète et plus sérieuse vous nous
annoncez des chiffres qui ne sont pas
étonnantes quand on compare deux régions
sur le public et le privé et que on y
prend l'investissement alors que
l'investissement pour le second degré et
soit interdit au mieux plafonné à 10 %
pour ce qui est du privé que les
collectivités territoriales respecte cet
interdit par est complètement normal
bon le public et le privé ce n'est pas
la même chose les performances si on
doit les mesures et par rapport au bac
il faudrait prendre en compte le zapping
de du parcours de chaque élève qui fait
que souvent il va dans le public on
primaire puis en collège dans le privé
pour ceux qui fréquentent le privé puis
terminent leur scolarité au lycée dans
le public mais on arrive à avoir des
comparaisons il faudra intégrer tous ces
données là et surtout reconnaître que le
public ne choisit pas ses élèves que les
20% des élèves en très grande difficulté
notamment ceux qui sont dans l'éducation
prioritaire sont dans le public que 97 %
des élèves qui sont en situation de
handicap sont scolarisés dans le public
que 97 % des élèves qui sont considérés
comme primo arrivants et donc ne
maîtrisons pas bien le français sont
scolarisés dans le public
et là on pourrait voir que la plus-value
va au public et je termine sur ces
comparaisons ce qu'il ya des
comparaisons qui sont autrement plus
intéressante c'est celle qui consiste à
penser que la nation investissent plus
pour la formation de ses élites déjà
trié que par rapport à aux élèves qui
doivent bénéficier d'un parcours commun
et donc quand on voit qu'on dispense de
deux à trois fois plus pour les élèves
qui sont classe prépa que pour ceux qui
sont en lice en collège ou en école
primaire
là aussi on a des interrogations à se
poser j'ai pas dit le contraire sur les
questions des lycées publics qui sont
sur dotées par rapport à d'autres
simplement là je compare par élève et
par an le coût entre public et privé
il n'ya plus faut pas avoir de tabou
dernière question
oui bonjour à tous c'est moins
d'ailleurs une question qu'une note
d'information je suis y voit qu'un
professeur à l'école normale supérieure
de lyon
peut-être de vous et je suis par
ailleurs depuis peu directeur mairie
faisait allusion tout à leur directeur
de lift et l'institut français
d'éducation qui a fait qu a pris la
succession de lee en rp l'institut
national de recherche pédagogique fin de
l'année dernière donc lhi en rp a été
intégré dans l'école normale supérieure
et c'est une manière de répondre à la
question de madame sur l'apport de la
recherche en étant dans un établissement
d'enseignement supérieur de recherche
on peut espérer effectivement que la
recherche injectera toutes ses
ressources dans le nouvel i fé mais en
même temps ceci en réponse à votre
marque sur le côté théologique des
sciences de l'éducation
nous avons gardé à ali fait cette
insertion et ce rapport très proche de
partenariat avec le terrain en ce sens
que nous avons une quarantaine
d'enseignants détachés une douzaine
d'enseignants détachés à un mi temps et
nous avons gardé un certain nombre
d'heures qui permettent de financer des
travaux sur le terrain même avec des
enseignants qui sont dans leur classe
donc cette articulation entre le terrain
et la réflexion universitaire peut se
conduire au sein de l'eee fait et peut
donc monsieur devoir répondre à des
demandes d'évaluation
nous travaillons à un nombre
d'évaluations d'expérimentation avec le
service de madame robert mais nous
pouvons aussi bien répondre à une
demande comme la vôtre
voilà je suis à votre disposition donc
merci de me donner la parole de la
mission souhaitent encore s'exprimer
donc je vais donc passer la parole au
sénateur carle
pour conclure cette matinée qui a été
très riche et je vous engage à
poursuivre la discussion par la suite
d'un déjeuner mais si dans les mois qui
viennent merci merci madame
écoutez je vais essayer d'être le plus
bref possible parce que je voudrais pas
que vous sans briller dans
l'hypoglycémie
sauf si on ré ouvre le débat sur public
privé sur la règle des 20 80 car là je
pense que personne ne sombrerait dans
l'hypoglycémie lent je voudrais tout
simplement d'abord remercier nos
intervenants de leur exposer et surtout
de la concision allées du temps limité
qui est qu on leur a laissé
ils doivent se sentir un peu frustré
mais ils pourront ça a été dit complété
par écrit ou nous recontacter s'il
souhaite préciser ce point de vue le
pilote dams et messieurs vous remercier
toutes et tous et à travers vous toutes
les personnes que nous avons rencontrées
tout au long de nos auditions où tout au
long de nos rencontres sur le terrain
pousser ses rencontres ses auditions qui
ont été particulièrement enrichissantes
et qui nous permettent aujourd'hui de
mieux connaître à l'organisation du
système éducatif puisque c'est l'un des
objets ou les objectifs de cette mission
de mieux appréhender les problèmes et
les difficultés 1 devant lesquelles
chacun des acteurs sont confrontés et
puis aussi les attentes et les
espérances y sommes en jeu pâtirait
aujourd'hui les conclusions de notre
rapport ça sera pas le moment venu du
mois de la matinée oui ça sera fait le
moment venu donc au mois de juin et vous
serez bien sûr toutes et tous invités à
la présentation de ce rapport et des
auditions que nous avons fait et des
visites sur le sur le terrain tant en
france a été dit nous sommes allés d'un
certain nombre de pays nous irons de
marseille
nous irons en bretagne et puis nous
irons aussi ça a été dit en pologne qui
a des résultats c'est intéressant au
niveau des
enquête pisa et toutes ses auditions
tout toutes ces rencontres elle nous
avons pu constater que tous les acteurs
que nous avons en côte rencontrés
reconnaissent que les résultats ne sont
pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on pourrait en
attendre et que le défi que nous devons
relever est à la fois celui d'une
meilleure efficacité et d'une mais plus
grande équité afin de sortir de la
situation que le président vous a
présenté
en introduisant cette cette journée
celle que vous connaissez 160 mille
jeunes qui sortent chaque année sans
diplôme et sans qualification
et puis aussi mois ce chiffre qui qui
qui m'obsède qui est qu'aujourd'hui un
fils d'ouvrier à 17 fois moins de chance
de préparer une grande école qu'un fils
d'enseignants ou qu'un fils de cadres
supérieurs et que c'est donc ce défi que
nous devons relever défi qui n'est pas
propre à notre pays nous l'avons vu dans
nos
visite aller à l'étranger nous l'avons
vu en hollande
nous l'avons vu en suisse ou au portugal
qui défis que rencontrent plusieurs pays
voisins et que tout ça ça passe je veux
dire par répondre à mon avis à deux
questions majeures la première c'est
celle de l'articulation entre le
ministère qui à mon sens doit être le
garant de la cohésion le garant de
l'équité sur l'ensemble du territoire et
les rectorats les rectorats qui doivent
être à mon sens un le lieu de cohérence
et de mise en place des politiques en
essayant d'éviter un écueil inquiets
celui ça ça nous a été dit ça me revient
lors d'une visite que les rectorats ne
doivent pas devenir autant de mini rue
de grenelle qui on n'aurait pas avancé
on aurait peut-être descendu d'un
échelon et par effet joule on
améliorerait peut-être les moyens
investis mais nous y perdrions à mon
avis en cohérence nationale en équité
sans bénéficier pour autant des
dynamiques locales et puis bien sûr le
troisième niveau qui est celui des
établissements où des bassins
d'établissement les réseaux
d'établissements qui sont les lieux de
l'action et pourtant ça a peut-être
s'inspirer de ce que nous avons voulu
répète au portugal en suisse ou en
hollande avec des j'allais dire des
systèmes très différents et parfois
opposées
et d'ailleurs c'est très intéressant
parce que on voit bien l'autonomie dans
lequel le portugal s'engage l'autonomie
réelle de la hollande
l'atomisation du système suisse c'est
mes voisins donc 26 cantons vingt six 26
systèmes éducatifs différents lors un
moment où on parle d'économie
là aussi il faut j'ai à dire rester
extrêmement
vigilant et que cette autonomie ça a été
dit là au cours de cette table ronde où
des deux tables rondes
c'est peut-être aussi au niveau du
réseau d'établissements à l'intérieur
d'un bassin de formation ou d'un basson
dit et puis la deuxième question c'est
sur la méthode je crois qu aujourd'hui
on le voit bien la méthode elle a
atteint ses limites et qu' aujourd'hui
je crois que ça y est là encore été dit
par nombre d'intervenants c'est celle du
partenariat mais d'un véritable
partenariat entre tous les acteurs pour
faire en sorte de véritablement rentrer
dans des compétences monsieur ans vous
avez évoqué la loi de 2004 pour entrer
dans des compétences véritablement
partagée alors qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes encore trop dans des compétences
séparées dans des compétences cloisonné
et d'agir simultanément
si on veut vraiment être efficace bien
sûr sur l'école de notre mission mais
aussi on le voit bien sur la famille et
en même temps sur la politique de la
ville
c'est comme ça qu'on fera avancer les
choses je terminerai en prenant une
conclusion de la commission thélot une
phrase qui m'est restée présente à
l'esprit qui était qui émanait
d'ailleurs je crois d'un proviseur ou
d'un principal de collège qui disait
notre école va bien pour les enfants qui
vont perdre mais je crois que notre
ambition à tous et de faire en sorte que
notre école est bien pour l'ensemble de
nos élèves et je terminerai sur la
phrase que nous a dit en ouverture le
président larcher
il fallait qu'on ait une école qui soit
semblable pour tous et respectueuse de
la diversité qui agit la diversité des
enfants des besoins de l'économie locale
et la diversité des territoires
voilà on va peut-être donc président
conclure cette table ronde
en vous remerciant encore très
chaleureusement de votre présence et
votre participation
c'est la fin de cette table ronde
consacrée au fonctionnement du service
public de l'éducation pour la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr je
vous retrouve cet après midi à partir de
17h pour suivre en direct la séance de
questions cribles thématiques consacrées
aujourd'hui à l'apprentissage très bonne
journée à tous